ALLEN ARCHULETA ATKINS BAKER
GORGEOUS BRADFORD CABALLERO
CORTESE DALLY DODD DORADO
EGGMAN GONZALEZ GROWTH
HERTZBERG HUESO HURTADO JONES
LAYERED LEYVA MCGUIRE MEN.
NEWMAN NIELSEN BUT CHAU VOGUE
PAN PORTANTINO ROTH RUBIO
SKINNER STERN AMBERG BY CASKEY
WIENER WILK. MEMBERS A QUORUM
IS PRESENT. WITH THE MEMBERS IN
OUR GUESTS TO BE ON THE RAIL
AND IN THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE.
WILL BE LED IN PRAYER THIS
MORNING BY SENATOR MAN AFTER
WHICH WE'RE GOING TO ASK YOU TO
REMAIN STANDING. AND WILL BE
LED IN THE PLEDGE BY SENATOR
NELSON. THANK YOU. GOD OF ALL
MERCY AND COMPASSION WE OFFER A
PRAYER FOR THOUSAND YEARS BY
JAMIE DANIEL. IN THIS CENTURY
AND IN ANY CENTURY OUR DEEPEST
HOPE OUR MOST TENDER PRAYER IS
THAT WE LEARN TO LISTEN. MAYBE
LISTEN TO ONE ANOTHER IN
OPENNESS AND MERCY MAYBE LISTEN
TO PLANTS AND ANIMALS IN WONDER
AND RESPECT. MAY WE LISTEN TO
OUR OWN HEARTS IN LOVE AND
FORGIVENESS. MAY WE LISTEN TO
YOU ARE GOD IN QUIETNESS AND
ALL. IN THIS LISTENING WHICH IS
BOUNDLESS IN ITS BEAUTY. MAY WE
FIND THE WISDOM TO COOPERATE
WITH YOUR HEALING SPIRIT YOUR
DIVINE SPIRIT. BECKONS US INTO
PEACE AND COMMUNITY AND
CREATIVITY. WE DO NOT ASK FOR A
PERFECT WORLD. BUT WE DO ASK
FOR A BETTER WORLD WE ASK FOR
DEEP LISTENING AND FOR THE
ABILITY TO RESPOND TO WHAT WE
HEAR. COMMENT. PLEASE JOIN ME
IN THE PLEDGE TO THE FLAG OF
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE. SIX JUSTICE
FOR ALL. MEMBERS TODAY WE HAVE
SENATORS BATES GLAZER LA MON
AND MELENDEZ PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY. GOOD MORNING SENATORS
AND WELCOME. MOVING ON THE FILE
ITEM FOR ME MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ. REPORTS FROM
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS. MOTIONS ARE
RATHER RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION JOINT
RULE SIXTY TWO AA WILL BE
WAIVED FOR THE BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW COMMITTEE TO MEET
FOR AN INFORMAL INFORMATIONAL
HEARING ON THE SUBJECT MATTER
CONTAINED IN S. B. EIGHTY SEVEN
TODAY WITHOUT FOUR DAY NOTICE.
IN THE DAILY FILE. MEMBERS
WITHOUT OBJECTION MEASURES WILL
BE REPORTED FROM THE BUDGET IN
FISCAL REVIEW COMMITTEE WILL BE
GIVEN THEIR SECOND READING UPON
BEING REPORTED IN ORDER TO
THIRD READING. MOVING ON
INTRODUCTION AND FIRST READING
OF BILLS SECRETARY PLEASE RATE.
SENATE BILL 539-540-5401 FIVE
FORTY TWO AND SENATE BILL FIVE
FORTY THREE. THANK YOU. WE KNOW
NOW CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY
FILE WE HAVE TWO ITEMS ON THEIR
GOVERNMENT GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS. I ITEMS FOUR AND
FIVE SENATOR HERTZBERG ARE YOU
PREPARED I AM INDEED MISTER
PRESIDENT. I'M SIGNATURE.
CENTER HERTZBERG THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR PRESIDENT FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR IS THE CONFIRMATION
OF DOUGLAS MCCAULEY IS THE REAL
ESTATE COMMISSIONER FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF REAL ESTATE PRIOR
TO HIS ROLE THE SERVICE CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT AND IS IT
EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF THE BOARD
OF ARCHITECTS HE WAS APPROVED
BY THE SENATE RULES COMMITTEE
ON FEBRUARY TENTH ON THE
UNANIMOUS FIVE ZERO VOTE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE APPOINTMENT. HEARING SEE
NONE MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BECKER.
I FOR JUST AYE BRADFORD HI
CABALLERO AYE CORTESE AYE DALLY.
I DODD I TORONTO HI EGGMAN I
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. I HERTZBERG
I HUESO. I HER TADO HI JONES I
LAYERED I LEYVA. I MCGUIRE FIVE
MILLION I NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN I
A TELEVOTE I PAN BY PORTANTINO
I ROTH I RUBIO. FIVE SKINNER I
STERN. AMBERG I WHITE HOUSE SKI
I WIENER AYE WILK HI. MMHM
SURGERY PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. STERN ONE MOMENT.
HIGHS THIRTY FOUR KNOWS IT ZERO
THE APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED.
WOMEN ON SENATOR URGED HER TO.
FILE ITEM FIVE. THE CURRENT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MISTER
PRESIDENT FILE UNDER FIVE IS
THE CONFIRMATION OF THE
FOLLOWING APPOINTMENTS TO POSTS
COMMISSION ON PEACE OFFICER
STANDARDS AND TRAINING FIRST
SERGEANT LIE LIE BULLY LITTLE.
SECOND SERGEANT BERRY DONLAN
THIRD OUR OWN JEFF LONG FROM
THIS LEGISLATURE OF BOTH HOUSES
SERVE WITH DISTINCTION HERE ARE
SO MANY OF US. FOURTH SERGEANT
JAMES- ARC AND FIFTH SERGEANT
BY TINA RAMIREZ ALL OF THESE
APPOINTMENTS MEMBERS WERE
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE
ON FEBRUARY TENTH ON THE
UNANIMOUS FIVE ZERO VOTE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSIONS
ARE DEBATE ON THIS APPOINTMENT.
RECOGNIZING SENATOR GLAZERS
REMOTELY. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT- AND MEMBERS- I AM
PLEASED TO SUPPORT VERY DONLIN
FOR APPOINTMENT TO THE
COMMISSION ON PEACE OFFICER
STANDARDS AND TRAINING MISTER
DUNLIN IS A CONSTITUENT OF MINE
FROM CONCORD HE HAS WORKED FOR
THE OAKLAND POLICE DEPARTMENT
SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND IT
SERVED AS A SERGEANT SINCE TWO
THOUSAND SIX. HE HAS BEEN
PRESIDENT OF THE OAKLAND POLICE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION FOR SIX
YEARS A MEMBER OF THE PEACE
OFFICERS RESEARCH ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA AND A MEMBER OF
THE PORAC LEGAL DEFENSE FUND
BOARD OF TRUSTEES AS SERGEANT
AT DUBLIN IS A PROVEN LEADER IN
LAW ENFORCEMENT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE FOR HIS
CONFIRMATION TODAY. THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE APPOINTMENT.
HEARING C. NINE MINUTES
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA. AYE ATKINS
AYE BAKER. GORGEOUS I BRADFORD
HI CABALLERO AYE CORTESE AYE
DALLY. I DODD I THE RISE SO I
EGGMAN. HI GONZALEZ I GROWTH. I
HERTZBERG AYE HUESO I HER TADO
I JONES I LAYERED I LEYVA. I
MCGUIRE. I MEN I NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN I A SHOW OF BOTH. I PAN
FIVE PORTANTINO. I ROTH. I
RUBIO I SKINNER HI STERN.
NUMBER I Y. CASKEY I WIENER. I
WILK HI HI. FIVE THIRTY FOUR
KNOWS I'M SORRY HIGHS THIRTY
THREE KNOWS ZERO THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED- I
TAKE A- BRIEF PRIVATE.
MEMBERS
WE'RE GOING BACK TO FOLLOW ITEM.
NUMBER FOUR. MAKING A
CORRECTION THE ROLE SHOULD.
REPRESENT ALL EYES THIRTY THREE
NO ZERO. THANK YOU. OUR MEMBERS
NOW MOVING ON TO COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS ARE THERE
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS SKINNER
SAID SENATOR SKINNER. YES THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS OF THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE WILL CONVENE
FIFTEEN MINUTES AFTER ONCE THE
FLOORS BEEN CLEANED. AFTER
SESSION CONCLUDES. CORRECT
BUDGET AND FINANCE WILL CONVENE
HERE FIFTEEN MINUTES AFTER. WE
HAVE CAN RECESSES TEAR AND THE
CHAMBER SENATOR ALSO. SEVEN
FIVE- BUDGET SUB FIVE WILL-
CONVENE AFTER THE LARGER BUDGET
COMMITTEE. OKAY BUDGET SUB FIVE
WILL MEET HERE IN THE CHAMBERS
AT THE CONCLUSION OF THE BUDGET
AND FINANCE COMMITTEE. I STAND
CORRECTED BUDGET SUB FIVE WILL
MEET IN. THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE.
I'M ON THE GERMAN OF BUDGET AND
FINANCE THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE.
IF THERE'S NO OTHER BUSINESS.
CENTER ATKINS THE DOSE IS CLEAR.
MISTER PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO
MUCH FIVE I HOPE EVERYONE HAS
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SEE THE
LANDING ON MARS TODAY JUST A
FRIENDLY REMINDER AS WELL I
WOULD LIKE TO WISH ARE PROBABLY
FROM FREMONT A VERY HAPPY
BIRTHDAY- AND IF THE PRESIDENT
ALREADY DID THAT FORGIVE ME MR
PRESIDENT BUT I WANT TO MAKE
SURE- THAT WE ACKNOWLEDGE HIM.
AND WITH THAT I HOPE ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE A VERY GOOD
WEEKEND AT HOME AND OUR NEXT
FLOOR SESSION IS SCHEDULED FOR
MONDAY FEBRUARY TWENTY SECOND
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AT TWO PM.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT. THANK
YOU MANNA PRO TEM. AGAIN WE
WANT TO EXTEND A HAPPY BIRTHDAY
TO OUR SENATOR FROM FREMONT AND
ALSO. A PRE EARLY BIRTHDAY WISH
FOR MARCH SENATOR. FROM NAY
INLAND EMPIRE WILL BE
CELEBRATING HER BIRTHDAY
TOMORROW SENATOR LEYVA. THE
SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL
THREE THIRTY AT WHICH TIME AN
ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE MADE
WILL RECONVENE ON MONDAY AT TWO
PM. THANK YOU MEMBERS.